these are two cy young candidates
tonight lin and glass now no it's really
a great pitching matchup last time out
against the blue jays he was magnificent
the fourth team fastball 43 times the
cutter 36. so it was fastball city the
sinker that's a fastball change up was
the way he varied from it
that's a hot shot up the left field line
off the bat of a rosa arena bond over to
make the pickup randy's going to head
for two and he is in there standing his
11th double of the year
two or two
he punched him out beautiful fastball
two down
well two gone for austin meadows
oh there's a shot well tagged and into
right and that baby is going to get out
of here
home run for austin meadows and the rays
grab a two-nothing lead
here in the first inning meadows 15th
home run of the year that will give him
an even 50 runs batted in
boy that ball was gone from the
beginning
he went to the bad area look at grand
all moving they want the ball away
and that pitch is down and in and that
is into the juice zone of a left-handed
hitter especially one that is swinging
the bat as well as austin meadows how
about this start
well you couldn't ride it any better for
the raise and tyler glass now taking
them out for his 14th start of the
season you talked about the strikeouts
in the open 117 in 84 innings
and there's a cup of mess
a good one is
out on strikes
first strikeout of the night
[Applause]
and a chase on that one
mercedes out of there one two three
first with two strikeouts two-nothing
range
the pitch
swing and a miss he got him on a cutter
that was a lane changer that ended up
two feet out of the strike zone that's
his second strikeout in the first out of
the inning two two there goes walls this
is low throw down to second base a good
one and he is out at second that was a
very good throw yes did a nice job of
getting it quickly and then getting it
down there
he got him he absolutely got him and i
mean he got him by an eyelash but he got
him
fastball toward the top of the zone and
that will end the inning lance lynn
couple of strikeouts and a quad ceiling
2-0 nothing in one to count in field for
the race looking to turn two
the pitch breaking ball grounded towards
second low has it flips the second out
walls is turned to first and plenty of
time it is a four six three double play
and that'll do it for chicago someone
out here in the third
brandon lau
this one is lifted down the right side
is it going to be fair
that ball is a
fair ball
and gone
right down the line brandon lau hits his
12th home run of the year
second home run for the raise tonight
and it's three-nothing tampa bay
another solo shot off lynn well this
team has a lot of guys that can hit home
runs but they also have a lot of guys
with big speed
cutter for strike three arose arena
didn't see it well and two gone
2-2
struck him out on the change-up upstairs
and the innings over
we got to the bottom of the third go to
devon
that's a strike on the outside corner
and vaughn walks away strikeout
number three for glass now
garcia is on his way to second a miss
handle for a rosariana but not enough to
get garcia to third it is a one-out
double for leori
you wouldn't imagine he'd throw tim a
first pitch fastball no slider oh right
in the door garcia's coming home he
scores three to one that was an
excellent read by laori garcia he was
off as soon as he saw the ball hit the
ground
good left side that's a base hit
tim on his way home it is three to two
if you get to him in the first two
pitches there's a jackpot waiting
and a chase
he got him on the slider to retire the
side and hold on to the lead 3-2
this one's clipped and did yes catch it
yes he did it's a strikeout for lance
lynn nice pick
by grandahl before it hit the dirt a lot
of pitches here not through the fourth
inning pitch number 74 on the way
3-2 again
on a fast ball he wanted to get him
outside he did
lance says forget about all of it
everybody can relate to that good on
base percentage double-digit home runs
yep there you go
he missed
the breaking pitch right there
out number one in the fourth and
strikeout number five
he gets
down to first and eaton is out of there
so back-to-back strikeouts it's three in
a row we got to bray you to end the
third they need to be resourceful they
don't have a huge payroll that's always
been the case rosarina
rips one into center and a diving catch
by brian goodwin not only did he lay out
heading toward the plate but he made a
late adjustment and had to reach far to
his left to make that grab as that ball
was starting to slice tyler glass now is
now out of this game after four innings
and
53 pitches but just watch the body
length of stretch that arm out a little
bit right there and it's still
stretching that elbow out i'm being told
that it is right elbow inflammation for
tyler glass now they're going to play it
safe and ryan thompson will get the call
and a swing and a miss that takes care
of mercedes and we're going to head into
the sixth the raise holding a 3-2 lead
2-0
on the ground up the middle and mendix
going to take it himself that's a
brilliant play by danny mendick danny
did it all by his lonesome and
exceptionally done lance is a very happy
man boom says lance lynn this is strike
three lance gonna go nuts
busted him and there goes lance lynn
erupting
lance lynn
keeping his team right in the mix
tonight india rosarita he doubled in the
first and scored on the meadows home run
3-2 that's lined into right field pretty
well tagged and that's going to get out
home run into the bullpen
opposite field home run by randy
rosarina and the rays are get up by two
an opposite field shot
on a 3-2 pitch
[Applause]
on the ground right side
close
[Music]
going to get a run
walls crosses the plate boy the speed of
phillips getting down that line so the
rays now have a 5-2 lead that is a good
job
ground ball right side allows
flip to first and the rays win this one
one two three nine three ground balls